be patient but be prepared for what
choosing between being the man that
people need you to be or the father that
your son needs you to be a me by that
you and I walk between two worlds but we
can only do that for so long everybody
arrows bat dropping bombs big belly
burger for everyone so there's a new
round of the Justice League ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet so I'll
explain what's going on with Deathstroke
we found out who died on the island and
we got our first big teaser for some of
the big villains stuff that's going on
in the background but just like on the
flash they're easing into their big
villains so Richard Dragon in Michael
Emerson are like the two really big
villains they're bringing on the show
but even though we didn't see them in
the episode I think we got a little
teaser for one of them at the end let's
do top 10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs
so number 10 were six months into the
future but they flash back to show you
what happened on the island
so everybody pretty much got away we
actually got an inkling from the flash
they said Cisco got help from Curtis and
Felicity getting Barry out of the Speed
Force so we knew that they would survive
but the big question I think was Thea in
Samantha so we got the answer that
Samantha is the person who died and
that's why William is with Oliver in
present day it's been in all the promos
for a while now so I don't think it's a
big surprise that Samantha's dead the
bigger thing is what's going on with
Thea and that actually has something to
do with Roy's character so number 9
because the actress Willa Holland who
plays Thea wanted to do fewer episodes
this season they had to find a creative
way to ride her out of the show so
putting her in a coma was their way of
doing that I think she'll come out of
that when either Roy comes back on the
show which he will this season or the
mid-season finale whichever of those
events happen sooner so when they said
she'd be in fewer episodes that doesn't
mean like one or two episodes that just
means like half the normal amount and
they do 23 episodes of sea
so she'll probably ride the bench in
present day but they did say number
eight even though flashbacks are over on
arrow they'd still be doing flashbacks I
know it sounds kind of funny so if you
remember how flashbacks used to work the
only change now is that other character
who will get flashbacks when they're
relevant for whatever their story is in
the episode so they said there'd be Thea
flashbacks there's gonna be some
Deathstroke flashbacks because when he
comes back they'll tell his origin story
I'll explain that in a second
but it'll just allow them to have a
little bit more fun but number seven so
in the flashbacks we find out why
everyone's so messed up in present day
Quentin's been messed up for a while now
so we find out that he actually tried to
kill black siren to protect Black Canary
and if he wasn't already staring down
the barrel of a gun thinking about
drinking himself to death
over the death of his real daughter
earth-1 Laurel black siren coming back
just completely twisted him up and then
he shot her so that's why he looks like
he's about ready to die when you first
see him in that bar staring at the shot
glasses all the dialogue is great - I
feel like the writing in this episode
and the way they shot it was totally on
point when Yuri watch the episode look
at how they start moving the camera
faster and faster through scenes to
build tension while the [ __ ] starts to
hit the fan so it just feels like
they're firing on all cylinders it just
feels like a much better show starting
off in episode 1 but speaking of which
number 6 almost everybody gets costume
upgrades and the most interesting one
yes the t spheres are really cool
they're getting much closer to
comic-book t spheres I wonder if he'll
ever fly on them at any point if arrow
goes to ten seasons maybe we'll see that
in season 10 but look at wild dogs new
costume whose costume does that remind
you of now so obviously it looks a lot
cooler than his costume last season but
it almost looks like he's vigilante like
was anybody confused the first time you
saw him you're like oh my god is that
vigilante but then you hear his voice
speak and you're like oh no it's wild
dog that feels like it's on purpose they
want you to visually associate him with
vigilante and they did confirm the
vigilantes a male character and
everybody on Team arrow has sort of a
nemesis this season like Black Canary
has black siren it feels like Wild Dogs
nemesis is going to be vigilante because
both of their special thing is guns
but that was just something that really
stood out in the episode to me just the
fact that he looks so much like
vigilante now number five racism made is
back if you don't remember her she was
actually in the pilot episode and then
we never saw her again so presumably
Oliver needed help raising William when
he was out doing vigilante and mayor
stuff so she's sort of filling in the
gaps he's having nightmares about the
bad man it every single time they have a
scene together for the first half of the
episode or so
William makes all of her cry by saying
something not trying to be mean but
being totally honest
the bad man is the reason my mother is
dead who's the bad man William and he
just points it Oliver and you can see
tears streaming down Stephen amell's
face but there are a couple Easter eggs
in his scenes as much of a bummer as
this is he kind of wins him over by the
end of the episode but the thing is is
that he's playing a video game and I
think it's injustice to he might be
playing as poison ivy there and then you
remember that he's a big fan of the
flash and green arrow maybe not so much
the green arrow anymore but he has his
flash backpack so maybe when we get to
the four night crossover Oliver will
introduce him to Barry because William
knows about the flash but he doesn't
know that Barry is the flash so that
just feels like a really easy way for
all of her to win cool dad points with
him number four was black siren just
blowing everything up so you have the
bunker fight then you have the police
station in Marc Guggenheim behind the
scenes said that there was a set that
they used a lot that was getting too
noisy for them to film on because of
construction that was happening around
it so right off the bat I assumed he was
talking about the island but they had
already made plans to move away from the
island just because they'd done it for
five seasons so it's like okay we need
to get away from Lian Yu
but he said that because they couldn't
use this set that they were gonna blow
it up during the episode so I guess he
was talking about the police station for
a minute I thought he might be talking
about the arrow cave but they spent so
much money building that set that I was
like there's no way they can blow it all
up and by the end of the episode they
sort of confirmed that theory they
didn't completely destroy the bunker but
number three they do find out that black
sirens stole an experimental tea sphere
for what they have no idea they play it
in a really vague way like what can the
tea spheres do what will she use it for
well it can do just about anything so
why things you stole it for either
Richard Ragan or Michael Emerson the
bigger villains of the season the thing
about Michael Emerson's character is
they said he wouldn't be a physical
threat to Oliver on Team arrow but he
would feel somewhat unbeatable so it
sounds like he'll be a more devious
techno based villain which is why I
think number two the big WTF at the end
of the episode people supposedly
learning that Oliver is the green arrow
them outing him on the news was
something that Michael Emerson's
character did now it could be Richard
dragon but Richard dragon feels like
more of a punch you in the face type of
villain using secret surveillance
information to out Oliver's identity to
the public feels like something that
Michael Emerson would probably do in the
sort of sidebar - that - is that someone
seems like they resurrect black siren
like she really was dead there on the
floor and somebody touches her and she
just wakes up so either this new
character who is either Michael Emerson
or Richard dragon has powers of
resurrection or some technology that
just helped bring her back from the edge
of death so I'm not so sure that they're
going straight back to resurrection
there's probably some other twist
because they got rid of the Lazarus Pit
because they didn't want that easy out
like oh we can just dip this dead person
in the Lazarus Pit we'll bring them back
so there's probably some other
explanation for this scene here but my
number one is Deathstroke
so he finds out where Jericho is he's
going away he'll come back in episodes
five and six
they'll tell his origin story you'll
learn what happened to him before Lian
Yu and how he wound up on the island and
a little bit more about his family so we
might get to see his wife Adeline cave
we might get to see his other children
Rose Wilson isn't a character on the
show right now but he does have that
older son Grant Wilson that showed up on
legends of tomorrow in that alternate
timeline future so we'll see how they
play it but they've already released
some footage of that this is what he
looks like so let me know in the
comments what did you guys think of the
episode there was some dialogue that I
couldn't quite hear so I may have missed
a couple of the Easter eggs the only
other one that I haven't mentioned yet
was the joke about Oliver running for
governor which i think is a joke about
the wire because if you didn't watch
that show the mayor who was actually
played by Aidan Gillen who's a little
finger on Game of Thrones eventually
ended up running for governor and
winning so I'm not actually expecting
Oliver to ever run for governor and they
also named dropped Tommy
tommy was my friend he helped me fit in
I would hardly call having a friend who
helped you get into trouble fitting in
but I like what they're doing with
father-son story lines you have Oliver
and William you have Rene and his
daughter you have Slade in his son so
the rewards of the season are very clear
like Oliver's reward will be William
winning him over and having a real
family a real relationship with him but
what'll happen is they're dropping the
trailer for Marvel's New Mutants movie
at midnight tonight so that'll be my
next video I'll try to post that as fast
as possible and then later in the
morning on Friday stranger things is
dropping its final trailer so those will
be the next videos but I'm doing a DC TV
QA for flash arrow anything else you
guys want to ask me from the DC TV show
so just leave all those questions in the
comments that'll post on Saturday I'll
announce the giveaway winner when I post
that while you wait for everything you
can click here for footage from the next
flash episode and you can click here for
my new Star Wars video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight